my name is Paul Marino I have the honor
to be dean faculty at Hillsdale College
and I will be the emcee of this CCA
faculty roundtable on Ronald Reagan I
teach a course myself in US history
since 1945 so it's very tempting for me
to want to jump in and give a talk
myself but I'll resist that temptation
just introduce our speakers
I'll also resist the temptation to
respond to I thought was the most
controversial statement made during the
conference Peter Robinson when he opened
his talk with the chant go Tigers
our first speaker will be Professor Alan
Carlson Alan Carlson is in his fourth
year as a visiting professor of history
here at Hillsdale in addition he serves
as president of the Howard Center for
family religion and society and as
international secretary of the World
Congress of families he's the author of
12 books including one to be released
next month entitled godly seed American
evangelicals confront birth control 1873
to 1989 apropos of this conference in
1988 President Reagan appointed him to
the National Commission on children a
post he held through 1993 next will be
professor David Rainey an associate
professor of history here at Hillsdale
College where he's been teaching since
the fall of 2005 before joining
Hillsdale faculty dr. Rainey taught at
Grand Valley State University and prior
to that at the University of Illinois
where he received his PhD in 2001 dr.
Rainey's fields and graduate school
included early America of the United
States since 1815 Britain since 1688 and
American literature dr. Rainey received
his a B from the University of Chicago
in 1991 where urine honors in history as
well as college wide honors at Hillsdale
dr. Rainey teaches courses and include
the western heritage and the American
heritage colonial America the founding
of the American Republic jacksonian
america and sectionalism in the Civil
War
dr. Rainey recently completed a
three-year term as director of the
college's Honors Program in addition dr.
Rainey is known for his publications
public lectures and participation in
academic conferences and panels he is
currently finishing a book about
the United States Christian Commission
in the American Civil War next will be
dr. Kevin Porteous who did not provide a
biographical sketch for me leaving it to
me to tell the story of his life in a
very risky choice
dr. Porteous is assistant professor and
the department formerly known as
political science he has been with us
since 2008 he earned his BA from Ashland
University in 2001 and his MA and PhD
from the University of Dallas he has
taught at Mountain View College and
Belmont Abbey College and teaches in the
graduate program in history and
government at Ashland University he can
also tell you the representatives and
demographic profile of every one of the
435 House districts whether you want to
know it or not welcome first dr. Carlson
thank you in the mid-1970s when Ronald
Reagan looked back on his period as
governor of California
he resolved that he had made two major
mistakes mistakes for which he tried to
atone while serving as president the
first of these mistakes occurred on June
14th 1967 early in his first term when
he signed California's therapeutic
abortion Act into law this was six years
before the US Supreme Court's well known
Roe vs. Wade decision which made free
access to abortion the law of the land
prior to this new 1967 law the state of
California like most states had tightly
restricted abortion to rare cases where
for example the pregnant woman's life
might actually be at risk
Reagan later admitted that this was
quote a subject I'd never given much
thought to this comment rings true for a
clear national debate on the subject of
abortion only began after Roe versus
Wade was decided indeed foes of abortion
in the late 1960s were dispirited and
disorganized with this bill sitting on
his desk Reagan began a crash course of
reading about abortion according to one
report Reagan soon was quoting Saint
Thomas Aquinas all the same his staff
convinced him that he should sign the
measure it had passed by veto-proof
majorities in the California Legislature
and Governor Reagan's aides argued that
the bill's language allowing abortion
only in cases of rape or incest or where
pregnancy would gravely impair the
physical or mental health of the mother
these could be tightly interpreted
through regulation
so reluctantly he signed alas was as
with the other pre ro state level laws
liberalizing abortion in the late 1960s
patients and doctors alike quickly and
greatly abused the mental health
provision the number of abortions in
California soared Reagan's Reagan's
second great self acknowledged mistake
came in 1969 when he signed into law a
measure which introduced no-fault
divorce to California it was the first
state to accept this recommendation from
the American Law Institute a prominent
legal think-tank on the surface no-fault
advocates promised that the measure
would reduce fraud and streamline the
divorce process into a less bitter
proceeding Reagan most certainly was not
aware at the time of the American Law
Institute steeper project to sever
completely private sexual morality from
public policy a goal to which no-fault
divorce
contributed as one commentator has
summarized before a no-fault divorce a
court discussed the divorce petition in
moral terms who was at fault say in the
case of adultery
to what extent after no-fault divorce
such a petition would not be discussed
in moral terms at all incompatibility
was all that had to be claimed and the
number of divorces in California climbed
sharply during the 1970s Ronald Reagan
reversed his position on these questions
regarding abortion he became a vocal
pro-life advocate even turning his wry
sense of humor toward the pro-life cause
during his 1980 presidential campaign
for example Reagan told the New York
Times I've noticed that everybody that
is for abortion has already been born
one of his close aides bill Clark would
eventually compile a 45 page document of
Reagan's quotes on abortion all taken
from his official presidential papers
Ronald Reagan even wrote a small book on
the subject entitled abortion and the
conscience of the nation it was
published by the human life foundation
in 1984 along with commentaries by
mother Teresa and the British writer
Malcolm Muggeridge here are some
passages from Reagan's piece we cannot
diminish the value of one category of
human life the unborn without
diminishing the value of all human life
the real question today is not when
human life begins but what is the value
of human life the real question for the
abortionist
and for all of us is whether the tiny
human being has a god-given right to be
protected by the law the same right we
have we must all educate ourselves to
the reality of the horrors taking place
inside the abortion centers Abraham
Lincoln recognized that we could not
survive as a free land when some men
could decide that others were not fit to
be free and should therefore be slaves
likewise we cannot survive as a free
nation when some men decide that others
are not fit to live and should be
abandoned to abortion or infanticide
well these are strong statements coming
from a sitting president indeed
according to the man who published the
book James McFadden Reagan's essay had
to be smuggled out of the White House by
a pro-life secretary who had access to
the Oval Office Reagan's top aides so
the story goes feared that publishing
such ideas before the 1984 election
would annoy pro-choice Republicans
Reagan didn't care let them be annoyed
Ragan also filled his administration
with strong pro-life advocates edwin
meese as Attorney General Margaret
heckler at Health and Human Services and
especially C everett Koop as Surgeon
General on matters such as marriage in
divorce ronald reagan became the first
president since Theodore Roosevelt to
openly and frequently comment on such
family questions some examples the
family is the bedrock of our nation but
it is also the engine that gives our
country life it is the power of the
family that holds the nation together
that gives America her conscience and
that serves as the cradle of our
country's soul from a talk to a Ness
panic American group the core of
Hispanic culture is the casa or the home
the almost mystical center of daily life
were grandparents and parents and
children and grandchildren all come
together in the Familia and the family
provides children with a haven of love
and concern for parents it provides a
sense of purpose and meaning in life
when the family is strong the nation is
strong when the family is weak the
nation itself is weak ironically the US
Department of Education became the
center of family policymaking during the
Reagan presidency many conservatives had
hoped that Reagan would abolish this
department alas just as with Halloweens
Michael Myers it's hard to kill a
federal agency
it always springs back to life instead
Reagan put in place a solid team of
pro-family people there William Bennett
as Secretary William Kristol as his
chief of staff and Gary Bower is
Undersecretary of Education among other
projects they produced a 1986 report the
family preserving America's future this
was the first attempt since the Theodore
Roosevelt administration to craft a
coherent Republic
family policy in 1987 Reagan issued
executive acute avartar 12 606 it
required family impact statements on all
proposed new federal regulations or
policies providing answers to questions
such as does this action by government
strengthen or Road the stability of the
family and particularly the marital
commitment does this action strengthen
or erode the authority and rights of
parents and so on 10 years later I
should note President Clinton canceled
disorder these then were some of the
ways the President Reagan sought to
atone for the mistakes he had made as
governor of California during the
turbulent late 1960s in so doing he
became a sincere and forceful pro-life
and pro-family president and so he
should be remembered thank you
I won't even bother trying to adjust
this microphone it's fool's errand well
thank you all for joining us for our
roundtable discussion this afternoon I
for one have very much appreciated the
many perspectives that our speakers have
offered on President Ronald Reagan and I
trust that all of you have done so I've
done the same well as I reflected on the
arguments that our speakers made over
the last few days
one assertion in particular troubled me
and it got me to thinking a bit more
about about Reagan and in particular
about the question of education which
I'll get to in a moment
the Honorable senator Phil Gramm whom I
admire greatly by the way just to make
sure that that that position is clear
senator Graham posited that governments
and institutions in general give people
definition as Senator Graham put it
governments and other institutions make
people what they are Americans he
claimed are pretty ordinary people who
have been made extraordinary by their
form of government well I have to take
issue with that at least to a certain
degree and I suspect Ronald Reagan would
have done so as well in his first
inaugural address Reagan reminded his
fellow citizens that quote we are a
nation that has a government not the
other way around and this makes us
special among the nations of the earth
unquote he then went on to quote dr.
Joseph Warren who was president of the
Massachusetts Congress during our
nation's struggle for independence and
Warren stated the following quote on you
depend the fortunes of America you are
to decide the important questions upon
which rests the happiness and the
liberty of
millions yet unborn act worthy of
yourselves in 1981 in Reagan's first
inaugural address he was calling upon
his fellow citizens to act worthy of
themselves by preserving the birthright
of Liberty for subsequent generations
clearly the government was not to define
Americans rather they were to define
their government the idea that people
will define their governments and not
the other way around has a long history
in North America in his 9th I'm sorry in
his eighth third time's a charm in a
1682 frame of government of Pennsylvania
I should know better I teach us every
semester every year in a 1682 frame of
government of Pennsylvania William Penn
opined that governments will reflect the
attributes of the governed government
spent asserted like clocks go from the
motion men give them and as government's
are made and moved by men so by them
they are ruined - wherefore governments
rather depend upon men than men upon
governments let men be good and the
government cannot be bad if it be ill
they will cure it but if men be bad let
the government be never so good they
will endeavour to warp and spoil it -
their turn well Penn stated clearly his
conviction that good government
necessitated good people and that good
people were made and not born wisdom and
virtue were qualities that according to
Penn quote because they descend not with
worldly inheritances must be carefully
propagated by a virtuous education of
youth and of quote Regan agreed
wholeheartedly with this assessment
quote freedom is never more than one
generation away
from extinction the Great Communicator
warned and echoing Pericles during the
Peloponnesian War Reagan went on to say
quote we didn't pass it freedom to our
children in the bloodstream it must be
fought for protected and handed on for
them to do the same like Penn Reagan
understood that education was not to use
a buzzword of the x value neutral
instead education was a means by which
the nation's youth could and should be
trained in virtue in his 1967 inaugural
address as Governor of California which
by the way coincided with the serious
campus disturbances of the late 1960s
which dr. Carlson alluded to a moment
ago in this first inaugural address
Reagan called upon university professors
as part of their instruction to quote
build character on accepted moral and
ethical standards unquote I should say
that Reagan met with limited success on
that front particularly in dealing with
faculty in University of California
Berkeley but I'll leave it at that
leave it your imaginations well like
George Washington before him
Reagan recognized an inextricable link
between religion and liberty freedom
prospers Reagan said famously when
religion is vibrant and the rule of law
under God is acknowledged and Reagan
stated flatly that quote without God
democracy will not and cannot long
endure and this of course reminds me of
a document that our freshman read every
year in the American heritage and that
of course is the Northwest Ordinance of
1787 and I'd like to remind all of you
that the third article of the Northwest
Ordinance which was passed of course by
the Confederation Congress and then
under the
by the Congress under the Constitution
of 1787 the Northwest Ordinance in its
third article said the following quote
religion morality and knowledge being
necessary to good government and the
happiness of mankind schools and the
means of education shall forever be
encouraged now of course we don't find
anywhere in these remarks an
encouragement to establish a Department
of Education but clearly there's a
there's an implication here that
religion morality and knowledge were all
necessary to good government and Reagan
understood all of this that without
religion and morality knowledge was
meaningless good government could be and
would be impossible
well Reagan understood well the
interrelationships between education
virtue and liberty and perhaps the
Gipper said it best when he said the
following if we ever forget that we are
one nation under God then we will be a
nation gone under thank you very much
all right good afternoon thank you all
for being here today and thank you too I
don't see dr. Kaspar anywhere but though
maybe there is no sir thank you for
inviting me and dr. miner thank you for
inviting me to participate in this panel
I want to make a couple of specific
comments and then and then move towards
something that's somewhat more general
first thing I want to do is is just as
dr. Rainey picked that Senator Graham's
remarks I'd like to go after professor
Hayward's
comments in in some greater detail and
Hayward made a based a good deal of his
argument on reagan's self education and
since we are here at an institution of
higher learning i would like to at least
tentatively make the pitch for a formal
education and therefore maybe justify my
own existence to some extent so look
reagan in large measure did educate
himself I don't even begin to deny that
but why did he self educate and I would
suggest that in no small measure was
because the education he had didn't
provide him with the training that he
needed to deal with the situations in
which he found himself beginning with
the Hollywood labor disputes in the
1940s he self-educated out of necessity
moreover think about the circles in
which he ran in 1940s and 1950s
Hollywood that is to say there were a
whole lot of people in 1940s and 1950s
Hollywood who were left in a position
for a variety of reasons where they had
to to one extent or another self educate
and many of them made disastrously bad
choices or simply withdrew themselves
from the struggle all together that is
to say
how many people started thinking about
these issues and for a variety of
reasons wound up as communists right now
this is not to suggest that self
education does not work we have examples
Reagan himself Abraham Lincoln Winston
Churchill but I would suggest to you
that those cases are at the very least
the exception rather than the rule it
took a particular combination of the
right sort of character in the
individual these are all people that are
that are allowed in at least some
circles at Hillsdale colleges great
statesmen it took a certain kind it took
a certain predisposition both to
learning and to good ideas right that is
not necessarily natural in the
individual right that is to say we're
not simply well I would argue that we're
not simply born knowing what is just and
what is unjust and therefore to simply
look at an idea and say you know what
this is a problem or yes this is right
right and a solid formal education can
go a long way towards setting a person
on the correct path and Heyward himself
conceded that reagan's formal education
did play a role in his future beliefs
when non Keynesian economics became a
viable alternative hayward asserted and
i think correctly reagan was amenable to
it it made sense to him because he had
taken his degree in economics
prior to keynes general theory of much
prior to the publication of keynes
general theory of money and credit that
is to say his formal education
predisposed him to see the wisdom in a
particular course of action when that
particular course of action became
viable later in his life so much by way
of education a couple of specifics about
reagan's actions reagan's political
actions as president one of the most
notable victories and this is something
that senator Graham
correctly pointed to in in his remarks
was what what he referred to as the
Reagan recovery and I would suggest to
you that the Reagan recovery began with
Reagan's 1981 budget which was of course
one of the most titanic battles in
modern political history one to which
senator Graham alluded specifically and
and at great length and but to note not
only write the success which he did but
also to respond to one of the criticisms
of that budget and that policy which is
that Reagan's policies put us on the
path of deficit spending a path whose
extreme fruits we are seeing before us
right now so that is a primary
accusation right to the extent that I
wish I wish I was as skilled with
graphics as say Peter Robinson was where
I could just duck in and out and
everything would be right there waiting
for me but that's that's not who I am so
there was an interesting chart put out
showing growth in the federal deficit
over terms in office and it showed that
all the explosions in growth took place
during the in modern history during the
presidencies of Reagan and George W Bush
right and not coincidentally the bars on
this little bar graph indicating that
were bright red right and that compared
to Reagan and George W Bush increases in
deficit spending under Barack Obama or a
pittance right in terms of adjusted
inflation adjusted numbers per capita
numbers and so on okay it's so in
absolute terms right okay right I would
suggest to you however that if one takes
a look back behind the simple numbers
right one sees a more interesting
pattern that is to say that the real
explosion in federal spending began
before Reagan took office right now the
obvious target here is going to be Jimmy
Carter but I'm going to refrain from
that is not only is it low-hanging fruit
but I don't think it's correct right
the real explosion in federal spending
begins with the passage of the 1974
Budget Act when you start looking at the
increase in federal spending as a
percentage a percentage increase in
federal spending year by year right in
one of Hayward's books he chronicles
that entitlement spending in which had
been increasing in a relatively modest
pace of something like 7 to 8 percent
under Nixon prior to the budget Act
began exploding not entitlement spending
but discretionary spending and a 26
percent rate that disk rent that
discretionary spending following the
budget act now this was a period of
mixed governance that is to say we had
Republican presidents and we had
Democratic presidents and the spending
continued to increase well what happened
what happened was fairly simple Congress
reasserted control of the budget process
over the president right didn't take him
out of the loop but created a whole new
congressional organization and
reasserted congressional prerogative
over the budget process in such a way as
to really marginalize the president's
ability to control federal spending
right every year the budget comes out
and somebody in Congress says that this
budget is dead on a rifle right it's one
of the rituals of Washington it happens
all the time but the real explosion took
place because the power over
discretionary spending or decisive power
over discretionary spending was placed
in the hands of a group of people who
have absolutely no incentive to control
it and so whether the president was
Republican or Democrat his power to
control the expansion of federal
spending was minimal by the time Reagan
took office okay what else about that
budget the Reagan recovery contained a
number of elements budget cuts tax cuts
regulatory restraint sound monetary
policy rate the reining and of inflation
and many of these things controversial
or not were enacted right but one very
important part of the Reagan program
saw more trouble than any other right
and the instinctive thing is to say well
the tax cuts yes the tax cuts were very
controversial right but what really got
sacrificed to make all the rest of it
work was spending cuts in order to get
enough support well first of all the
Democratic House didn't want to pass any
of the spending cuts but to get enough
support each congressman had to start
each congressman had to be essentially
bought right keep your program if you
vote for the rest of the package right
this was the price of getting the larger
bill passed right and it was a very
difficult thing on the part of the
Reagan administration to prevent that
from becoming a feeding frenzy okay so
that much by way of Reagan's recovery
and budget program and deficits next
regulatory restraint
Rayden was elected in part on a policy
of regulatory restraint reining in the
administrative agencies and bringing to
heel the exploding modern administrative
state in this regard he was not
successful but but it was an instructive
failure that is to say the growth of the
regulatory state slowed under Reagan but
did not stop and the acceleration
resumed after his presidency the
instructive part of it is that what we
have realized right from the Reagan
lesson is that it is not possible it is
not possible to bring to heel the modern
regulatory state from the White House
right and it clarified something for us
very fairly I think simple concept if
you want to rein in the modern
regulatory state it must be done through
Congress Congress created it Congress
ultimately controls it only Congress can
bring it to an end right not the courts
right the president we saw congressional
resistance overcame presidential desire
to control it Congress it may surprise
you to believe is perfectly capable of
ignoring the Supreme Court when it
chooses to do so let me give you one
quick example in 1983 Congress rule or
the
Supreme Court ruled something called the
legislative veto unconstitutional the
idea that Congress or Committees of
Congress or one house of Congress could
void out an action by an administrative
agency since that ruling in 1983 which I
believe is utterly correct Congress has
included more than 500 legislative veto
provisions in legislation and none of
them have been challenged okay finally
Reagan and the founders principles and I
hope I'm not going overtime here right
professor Hayward correctly said in my
opinion that the central animating theme
of Reagan's thought was at the that
unlimited government destroys Liberty in
any form unlimited government in any
form destroys Liberty Reagan's grounding
for this understanding was I think in
the principles of the American Founding
and what Reagan realized was that that's
the only sound basis for resisting the
advance of the modern state it's the
only principal basis for doing so he
refers Peter Robinson referred to the
speech 1964 Barry Goldwater speech and
you saw excerpts of that being played
right and never mind the lack of
optimism in that speech the basic
philosophy is there he refers to the
founding fathers repeated repeatedly he
refers to their understanding of natural
and unattainable rights explicitly as
the alternative to rights as a
dispensation of government he refers to
government by consent as the alternative
to government by experts and he makes it
clear right that government that sets
out to do the things that the modern
state does is tyrannical by definition
it cannot help it cannot help but but
commit and justices and oppressive seven
citizens that is to say it's not bad
because it's an effective it's not bad
because it's incompetent right moreover
it's injustice is not an incidental
feature of the system it is a necessary
consequence of the existence of the
system
and by grounding his resistance to the
modern state in the founders principles
and their constitutionalism he made it
politically acceptable to talk about
those things again which for those of
you who don't remember the time before
the Reagan years somebody asked a
question about Reagan's Supreme Court
justices it really wasn't anybody else
the pickings were so slim right because
the idea that we should actually be
faithful to their principles their
intentions and the words of the founders
was utterly laughable in political and
legal circles and Reagan made it
possible to talk about those things
again and that might these greatest
accomplishment thank you very much
we can now open the floor to questions
for the panelists we have the microphone
bearers if you would just signal to them
to
you
you
he was asking did Ronald Reagan do
everything he could do to stop abortion
while president and if not what might he
have done is that your question I think
he did a great deal
he again he he placed a lot of good
people in public office we have to
remember our presidents constrained
multiple ways in terms of who's
available who's he's got political debts
to pay he's got advisors who have their
own lists of people they want to see in
places with that said he did a very good
job I some splendid people wound up
working in government with some real
effect one I'll just give you one
example
Carl a friend of mine Carl Anderson
became the chief counsel to the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
in the first term and kept the first
Secretary of Health and Human Services
moving in the right direction she might
not have moved in the right direction
without Carl being there he went on to
be a White House aide and today he's
running these he's the supreme Knight of
the Knights of Columbus a fine guy all
through middle and senior level
positions Reagan made good appointments
koop as a Surgeon General was Bruce
brilliant koop was a strong flow of
abortion he'd co-authored books with
Francis Schaeffer on abortion very
controversial appointment but he did
things like that
Reagan endorsed major pro-life
legislation in Congress but remember he
faced mostly a hostile Congress these
measures did not work their way through
but the human life amendment he endorsed
honestly and sincerely whatever he had a
chance to say something in its favor he
did no so I think given the constraints
that any presidents faces I think he did
he did quite well as president he faced
a hostile Congress most of the time he
was again faced I just stress again the
constraints that any president faces I
mean the fact that sometimes you have to
even as president have to work around
your own aides and that that's came up
to come up several times in this this
this week kind of Risa jests that this
is not an all-powerful person it's
someone who funds himself oftentimes in
a very difficult and complicated
political situation but I would give
Ronald Reagan of at least an A for his
efforts okay yeah Hillsdale Hillsdale a
well I'm not entirely sure how I got
appointed I think it was because of that
group at the Department of Education I
knew I knew bill Bennett somewhat I knew
William Kristol Bill Kristol and I knew
Gary Bower and so I think that was I'd
help them on that one project I
mentioned on that document so I think
that was why how I got a pointer what it
was was a unique event Congress created
the National Commission on children
to report on the status of the America's
young 36 members 12 appointed by the
president 12 by the Speaker of the House
and 12 by the President Pro Tem of the
Senate well the way that worked out in
1988 is that 24 Democrats 12 Republicans
so it was a monstrous task Jay
Rockefeller senator from West Virginia
was the chairman the Commission was
really active 19 1989 291 through a
miracle I can't don't have the time to
tell you all about it but through a
miracle the final report of the
children's commission was really quite
good called beyond rhetoric and it came
out of 1991 its but the Democrats wanted
was a brief Commission report which
recommended increased funding for a
variety of federal programs to support
children more money for Head Start or
money for daycare subsidies more money
for this more money for that but the
final report came out as it was mainly
because the conservatives on the panel
we did our homework and we worked hard
the liberals thought the staff would
deliver what they wanted Rockefeller
turned to be a remarkably fair chairman
and the final report which was which he
browbeat his fellow Democrats into
voting for it much to their anger and
disgust
it's principal recommendation was we
needed to relieve financial pressures on
American families of taxation so that
was worth $1,000 per child tax credit
idea first surfaced as a politically
viable thing and most of the other
recommendations of the panel were quite
good and indeed most of them are
actually eventually adopted usually in a
bipartisan manner so it was I was really
proud of that
and I think it did good work that's
right
I'm sorry I didn't hear the very last
part of it what role
yeah I wonder if my concern is that and
the reason I the reason I tried to bring
it up in this way was I don't know that
there's any kind of institutional
solution to the problem in other words
the the difficulty lies in sort of the
the fallen an incomplete nature of the
human condition itself and you're sort
of just the the odds of having the right
kind of person just like you can't you
can't run somebody through a meat
grinder institution and have a statesman
at the end then work that way right it's
contingent on factors which are inherent
in the character of the individual
person now what those factors are I
could only I could only guess about in a
sort of preliminary way a certain
predisposition towards certain
conceptions of justice but and so and so
it's really of for me it ends up being a
very hit-or-miss thing I mean my I think
my example is a valid one of Reagan's
coworkers in Hollywood and how many of
them were when left to analyze the
issues for themselves made devastatingly
bad choices you see it sort of not in
the same way but I see it in questions I
get from people who are active in the
Tea Party movement and that's not to say
the tea that don't equate them with with
already Shaw in these guys and that's
not the point right and it's not it's
not that it's not that they're not
capable it's that they've had a
defective education many many people
have they know it right but they have no
idea where to turn right and so they're
just kind of grasping right and one of
the nice one of the one of the great
things about being in Hillsdale is is
that you get to work with those people
and so when when they ask you a question
you can provide them with a reasonably
intelligent answer right
but sometimes you look at the questions
and say you know if it weren't for the
right guidance where would this person
end up the last question I got of this
nature was is the supercommittee
unconstitutional the supercommittee is
the one that deals with with the federal
debt right without going into too much
detail the short answer is no but you
know in other words that's actually not
a bad case scenario it's not a worst
case scenario because the worst thing
that happens there is you sort of get
led down a constitutional interpretation
blind alley right but if your choice is
between Communists and free well if you
make if you go down the wrong path it's
more than a blind alley so I don't know
if that answers the question or not but
that's that's what I can say
so to speak
dr. Rainey in near talked you freedom is
never more than one generation from
extinction and my question is are we
that last generation before the
extinction and if so how do we make it
so that doesn't happen well I know claim
to being a clairvoyant
I left my crystal ball back in the
office because the closest thing is this
bottled water but I don't think that's
gonna work too well your your question
is a fair one do I think we're that last
generation that Reagan talked about
before the the this this loss of freedom
I would I would like to say no I hope
that that's not the case but I think it
does speak to Reagan was was well aware
of how fragile liberty and freedom in
fact are and that's why he and and
others have placed such premium on this
process of transmitting these these
virtues to future generations because
without good people you can't have good
government and that's something that
certainly our founders acknowledged you
know for all of their wisdom and
creating a very useful mechanical device
of checks and balances and of course
separation of powers still they
acknowledge they realized that without
the people being good without the people
possessing virtue all of that was for
naught and so certainly Reagan realized
that that the freedom that Liberty is in
fact fragile and that it's it's very
easy to to lose it without making sure
that that the young people of the nation
fully understand the nature of Liberty
understand the responsibilities that
Liberty carries with it something of
course that we say great deal about here
at Hillsdale and the question of
responsibility keeps keeps coming up and
Reagan Reagan knew that he understood
that that freedom of Liberty took
sacrifice he was of course willing to
sacrifice on his on his part and he
expected his fellow Americans do that as
well he
Feeny called them to essentially rise to
the occasion he was very inspirational
to that effect I think in his first
inaugural address and in subsequent or
to all good performances but I would say
just to to sort of wrap things up that
that it's in my view it's not too late I
think that Hillsdale is part of that
effort to to get people to take virtue
seriously and to understand that there
is in fact a connection between virtue
and liberty and that without without
virtue without a citizenry that
possesses virtue civic virtue then we're
Altima lost and so I I'm hopeful but
certainly there are very troubling signs
particularly in the Academy Hillsdale as
you probably all know is an exception to
the rule and we're talking about the
role of formal education if you speak to
some of your friends who may be perhaps
go to Big Ten schools or even the Ivy
League's what are those students being
taught about virtue
what are they being taught about the
prerequisites of good government are
they receiving an instruction that does
have a moral component to it that
emphasizes emphasizes virtue and I would
argue in most cases no the education is
to use that buzzword again it's it's
value neutral there is no transmission
of values and if there is they're not
very good values they're not the values
that that we espouse and are certainly
not conducive to good government so yes
that makes me pessimistic but but
obviously all of you in this audience I
think are part of this effort to
reintroduce morality religion properly
understood and virtue into the
educational process and it must be there
it must be there without it our system
of government is in fact doomed there
any way I can stick my nose in that just
a little bit I not just not to disagree
with anything dr. Rainey says in any
form but we have a tendency I think and
to be somewhat
and not just us I say we in the broader
sense human beings to be somewhat
apocalyptic about our prospects and I
would I would suggest to you that this
is not to sit this is not to suggest
that the the the the situation which we
find ourselves right now is sort of any
is any idyllic conclusion to to the
struggle for liberty but imagine if you
were imagine if you were someone who
held sort of Hillsdale type principles
in 1858 this was not a good year for
Liberty and I think it looked much worse
than in the Dred Scott decision in
Kansas Nebraska and so on that it does
now or say in 1940 1941 for freedom
right at least it sure looked that way
with the fall of France in the Low
Countries and and right the the the
world was basically dividing itself up
into Nazi and communist and those were
many people were thinking that those
were your choices which is rather
amusing to think about in 2011 but made
serious people were thinking along those
lines so it's it's this is not to say
that we have no problems but to sort of
be put those problems in their proper
perspective
this questions right to dr. carlson was
wondering as you were mentioned before
you made the quote that uh when the
family is strong the country is strong
and have you seen any resembles in the
past twenty thirty years or so where the
family and the family core and its
values have declined drastically have
led to where we are today if or is that
not as big an issue as it may be no it's
a very big issue and probably unbalanced
things are getting worse despite best
efforts of a lot of people over the last
several decades including myself why is
why that phrase is more than rhetoric if
families are strong they don't need a
whole lot of government to take care of
them they're able to take care of
themselves they're able to provide
education for their children they're
able to protect their children they can
take care of their of their old people
they're dependent they're sick when when
the family fails on all those tasks
somebody's got to do it and voluntary
organizations if there's just too much
of that burden there or overwhelmed well
involuntary over organizations have
become overwhelmed and they can't handle
it and the only recourse is government
so that's why I think that there's truth
in it are things getting some things are
getting much worse yeah which is one one
statistic births out of wedlock in the
United States a tiny percentage in
nineteen forty the number began growing
among african-americans in the 1950s and
it appears that misguided welfare policy
was part of the cause of that the
subsidies for unwed mothers were
actually too high
whatever the cause that same practice
spread among started to spread among the
white population in the sixties and
seventies by by the year 1995 about
thirty six percent one out of over one
out of every three births was outside of
marriage then it seemed to stabilized
for about five well close to ten years
that number just stopped growing and it
looked like oh we've done something
right welfare reform in 1996
certainly reduced the incentives to have
a child out of wedlock
but then in the last three or four years
that number has started to climb again
it's now up to 40% and it's climbing
about one or two percent a year pretty
soon we will be that will be like the
welfare states in Sweden where the
government is seen as the natural
support mechanism for children so that's
one one could choose other examples of
weakening there are some things that are
good that are happening if I was to
point to the positive side things like
home schooling a revolution that nobody
saw coming in say 1975 it's a revolution
in education parents are reclaiming
their right to educate their children in
their own way now it's it's growing
still grew and and that's that's a very
positive thing the effort to a growing
number of family businesses small family
businesses I think again is an
extraordinary thing trying to bring
economic activity back into the home
trying to again crease a sense of
autonomy rather than reliance on big
institutions in every place so I could
point to some very positive things
happening but overall the marriage
statistics of birth rate statistics
divorce statistics are not in general
getting better except in some
communities
thank you I'll let the four of you
decide who will answer my question but
I'm wondering how the debate over
Reagan's success and greatness as
president has evolved over the past few
decades both among the public and in
academics you just make one one brief
comment and this might be in keeping
with what dr. Portillo said a moment ago
that we often have a tendency to
romanticize or to idealize the past and
I think that's certainly the case with
certain aspects of Reagan's record and
the other night there was a discussion
about the appointment of Justice Robert
Bork and I would be one of the first and
perhaps only to argue that the
nomination of Bork was not an unalloyed
good ok good I've got support thank you
brother
and I I do remember the the battles over
his nomination and at one point of
course Bork was soliciting assistance
from a number of organizations to help
lobby Congress on behalf of his
nomination and one of the organizations
he approached was the National Rifle
Association and I can recall talking to
Bork about this after the fact course
he's quite disgruntled and at the time I
was actually working at the NRA and he
got this very sour looking space and
said well you guys just didn't help me
out and I said well sir I said you've
gone on record as basically saying you
do not believe that the Second Amendment
in effect preserves protects an
individual right keeper arms instead you
adopt a collective rights interpretation
well yeah I kind of have been hard but
he said well I did rule the NRA in a
different case involving possessions of
firearms in the district but I think
things like that often go overlooked and
again had more Kuenn added to the court
I have no doubt that he would have
provided quite valuable contributions
many respects to our jurisprudence
however in one key case which decided in
2008 he may very well have gone a
different direction
and we wouldn't have the Heller decision
which we have today so I think again
time has a tendency to to obscure
certain facts people tend to romanticize
the past and that is often problematic
and I'm just providing one example of
that if you're asking how we how
historian's and commentators are
measuring the Reagan presidency today
compared to say 33 what he when he left
the presidency it seems as though his
reputation is growing I mean that's my
impression judging from even the
standard lists and places like the New
York Times he's seen as a strong
effective president and I think
certainly one of his legacies was the he
faced down the Soviet Union and I mean
one again an amazing amazing victory
that in 1980 would never have been
predicted now there were other factors
and other causes but I think if he had
he was a necessary actor in that if he
had not been there I think something
else probably would have happened I
don't know what it would have been worse
but I think generally his his reputation
seems to be growing right now certainly
the the centenary of his birth has
brought forth many tributes even Barack
Obama tries to quote him whenever he can
so to try to let some of the magic rub
off I would also note though picking
picking up where you left off that I
think you're gonna see progressives
liberals and you've seen you saw some of
it around the time of his birthday
attempt essentially the same
body-snatching expedition which they did
with Abraham Lincoln that is to say they
had there's this guy who's unabashedly
popular
so let's apropriate him and wash over
all the things we disagree with and try
and reinterpret him in Lincoln's case is
a proto progressive and in Reagan's case
says one of the things that Obama likes
to do is say Reagan would have done this
right and and so that's just one example
but an attempt to reinterpret
shi-it attempt to reinterpret readiness
as a sort of crypto liberal whom we
whose really progressive if you really
get past all the things he said it did
he's really really one of us so I would
I would it's it's it's worth that it's
worth watching I think yeah I think I
think you could see that when Reagan odd
I'm waking up all when Reagan died
I remember watching some of the you know
commemorations and I said I can't
believe this was the same guy you know
the same networks treating him the way
they did in the 1980s and one of our
speakers noted that liberals are
starting to come around to give Reagan
his his do that the sort of the hidden
hand rehabilitation of Eisenhower was
going on with Reagan I think that's the
case
Reagan stock is rising with liberals and
it started to fall with conservatives
you're seeing more and more
conservatives who are critical of Reagan
frezzer gamble isn't here but he's
written some very interesting pieces
about Reagan really sort of disputing
that he was a conservative at all so
that may be something to look for in
Reagan's a reputational future I'm sorry
but we are just about out of time it's
five o'clock so please join me in
thanking our panelists